نفخه من دخان متعه عند البعض نقمه على
اخرين قد يعد بعض الناس السجائر
الالكترونيه عموما اكثر امانا من تدخين
سجائر
تجاره في المملكه المتحده يقولون انهم
قلقون بشان التدخين الالكتروني او ما يعرف
بالغيبين وزياده المبيعات للقاصرين
ممنوعه لذلك في الكافيين والتوريين
محظوران في بريطانيا وقد تحتوي هذه
المنتجات على تلك المواد وما يثير القلق
ايضا عندما توجد فيها منتجات ممنوعه تحوي
ما بين خمسه وعشره اضعف المستويات
القانونيه
في بريطانيا على الاشخاص الذين تقل
اعمارهم عن 18 عاما ولكن وفقا لبحث الاجره
مع هذا المعايير التجاره فان الاطفال
الذين تقل اعمارهم عن اثني عشر
13 عاما
يستخدمونها بكثافه
صاحبها هذا المتجر الذي يبيعه سجائر
الالكترونيه يدعو الى تطبيق عقوبات صارمه
على كل من يخالف القواعد
القوانين من الواضح ان القوانين تطبق ومع
مراعاه كل شيء ربما نحتاج الى ان تطبق
بشكل اكثر صلامه
ان المراهقين والشبان الذين يستخدمون
السجائر الالكترونيه هم اكثر عرضه
للانتقال الى تدخين السجائر العاديه
وقارنه بمن لم يلجا الى تجربتي الاجهزه
الالكترونيه اصلا
وعلى الرغم من كونها اداه مفيده للمدخنين
لتقليل السجائر او التوقف عن التدخين
التبغ فان هذه المنتجات تجد طريقها بسهوله
الى ايدي المراهقين